divertimento in südafrika mit
globetrotter m spezialist für
maßgeschneiderte reise wald wie
globetrotter der punkt ch 23 woche lang
und wachs
es ist jede marktsituation in die ich
mache tournee
[Musik]
april und juni vor direktem intel geist
durch südafrika wichtig für die
wirtschaft wo mangels unter dem alltags
drucks freundlich erwartet und jetzt ist
das ist ein riesen chance ein tor in
drei wochen oder drei wochen unterwegs
sind zusammen
vor ihnen liegt 30 kilometer
ich glaube dass wir positive
errungenschaft
sicher wichtigeres für die 2 inzwischen
70 jährige schwört die intensivste sind
sehr oft mit russland sondern eher
gegenteilig und das user vor den letzten
zwei jahren miteinander wachsen sich
schon zustand
ich hoffe es nicht
[Musik]
kapstadt ich für tony levin es 2 2
sie hätten immer wieder die verstaubte
[Musik]
nicht das ist unfassbar
irgendetwas macht's möglich
[Musik]
juni hat sexy model ferien monitor
fdf rodach ausständig der mann ist
nämlich noch nils kopf statt
[Musik]
so
darunter fallen
so geht's das ist laut het
die des lebens wie es mit den hohen
findet
[Musik]
wenn johnny wohne ich im moment sitzt
verliert
[Musik]
das ist ja klar ich jetzt werde ich dann
gerne hinter die kamera
doch es ist mein team konnte in
südafrika ich weiß dass ich die tour
wird treffen war ja vor allem ihre
betriebliche vor mir aber geistig freuen
extrem ich wollte mit der kindliche
neugier ist der bagger und das alles auf
mich alle besucher seien kurz garten ich
freue mich dass wir nichts machen und
mit dem ganzen team oder und struktur
zusammen
der johnny wittstock allerschönste
zeigen unterkunft ist schon mal einen
guten hoffnung
die schnabel saison sieglos unbezahlbar
das jetzt vorgelegt das in nordendorf
zeige dass der morgen denn da und und
ihr dem dach zeigen das finde ich so
weit von der gegend hat jeder für sich
bucket list gemacht was er sich rat
nicht in jeder um kraft und lag in der
luft doch ich habe drei organisationen
sowie hat 27 populistischer portal ist
das quecksilber nicht unbekannt und ich
habe bock ist was ich gerne mal wird
zeigt in südafrika schon im nächsten
letztendlich beide sehr neugierig und
begeistert ist die mannschaft komplett
muss man sich für 3
viele glauben findet dann gefasst sind
zu sehen mit verteidigen wäre die
montage der leyen sei der wertete größte
rolle der stadt gerufen und komischen
shakespeare prächtige kap der guten
hoffnung toborg sehr gut stand womit
klassen mit dem er seine vier räder auf
rhode dürfen wir uns klug achte
gospelgottesdienst nicht unbedingt
afrika kommt carlo janka
das übrige familie woche lang live aus
gips pittsburgh halten
[Musik]
egal ich danke dir für kinder ist das
damals schossen daniel shek setzte sich
locker weg die andere natürlich noch
nicht aber ich nicht wie man mir kommen
weiß ich es gut finde ich dass er damit
ihm das ist nur eine hand wo immer
schimpft mitnutzt mit 3 das glaube ich
ihm wie den frauen mit sky tree mit zu
einem vor seinen rund um die uhr um mini
frauen und kinder maxi
übrigens stehen
wir sind nicht die 2 wie schön wäre vom
vorbereitet
in drei stunden hunderte wohnung und
essays und apple
das ist wie in schottland und ich werde
schön dass wieder afrika zone afrika
urwald mehr und das beste daraus und
singen das lied stillstand flüthmann vcw
bison unterstützt vom afrikanischen
kontinent
[Musik]
damals zinskupon durch schottland
qualität hat sich die 25 nummer im
schnitt bis zu
da ich freue mich wirklich nervös dass
ich wurde dann ebenso viel geld abgeholt
der flughafen aber dass ich jetzt mal
das ist so speziell
der toni ich friere losgefahren damit
pünktlich bereit stand
klassisch blöd sie haben vier
gepäckstücks mit dem untergehen sehen
wir jetzt droht zur stresst früher wie
sie es getan zwar dass sie durch ihre
worte finden stunden später
[Musik]
für die geistig voraus wo kapstadt uns
vor die beide krieg der südafrikaner
wird in zwei bezahlten auto doch die
erste weltcup statt
[Musik]
bio ist in südafrika ums definiert sich
zum glück schnell
[Musik]
so oft sie
nach der gelungenen reis namens der
hänger hat nokia aber morgen geht es los
mit der alten afrika und mit der 10
überraschen die branche hatte manu schon
hinter sich haben möchte mich net
basierende evonik von johnny übernachtet
es ist eigentlich absurd will ihn
eigentlich glaube ich hier einiges mehr
nur troubles mit der boni und nicht
funktioniert und die handgeführte besser
für mich völlig absurd ist wenn ich da
eigentlich gerade die luke der imposante
tafelberg und direkt von der nase
traumhaften start klappt stolze eine vor
der schönste steht auf der waldseite
dollar beliefen lügt wie ihre stadt zu
große panik gibt es seit über 25 jahren
nimmt trotzdem pro liter jedem ecke
waltenhofen und der johnny zeigten - 10
plump oder stolz
das ist etwas das baby da gibt es so
viel zu entdecken dass eine
produktionszeit die spannungskurve die
verschiedenen gut vorbereitet scheinbar
relativ friedlich das mega spannend
verständlich tage lang verbringen
aber es ist eben auch das mercedes
interviews ist immer so dass man abfall
und aber darauf habe porsche und bin das
ist die recherche hätte die chef dass
ich gerade damit da muss man neben den
frankfurtern
was ging es nach nord sie und mit einem
lässigen kurs kasse betroffen nicht
schwierig da wir mit touristen auf
rostocks klimatour und liegt an der
langen bericht statnett voraussetzt mehr
weiß wo man ohne selbst und wo liebe zur
region und sich evtl
ein strauß mit patienten schritt damit
dass du das machst eine platte und das
ist mini wohnung der besichtigung ich
leite noch möglich
[Musik]
waterfront ist beliebt dich die gerichte
nur den bund südafrika jedes jahr mit
drei millionen die der ehemalige
arbeiter hofstraße und flory
der manu service ganz bestimmt nämlich
die torgelow der wupsi bucket list
geschrieben hat der daniel wenn jahr
verschafft ganz besonders
sie sind das blech börse sowie im s 400
der townships der ordner 4 gemacht hat
[Musik]
imperium autohersteller sympathische
typen die zurück
der mono es gibt viele bands der rock
sound ich sie nicht ganz geschafft
[Musik]
gut gehen heute gesetzte ok und zur burg
loslassen damit dass vereine dem
flugzeug und ich hab sie geöffnet ist
[Musik]
und wie begann mit dem drehstart
programm
aber jetzt sondern wandert und sword of
the lions herz vorsicht der zweiten
person knappen tafelberg vor den oberen
reststoffen und moby lines
bis zum gipfelkreuz sachsen mit minus
acht metern stoppt genkov
der junior und regelmäßig der uv
rechtzeitig zum sonnenuntergang
das ergebnis wird erhöht mit dem motto
teile
[Musik]
so wurde
monika nachtruhe dass man sich sagen
übrigens nicht von prof
[Musik]
langenfeld
ein zeit gefunden so schön
wow
[Musik]
ja ich nicht beiseite crazy stellen
zulegte
ich habe ich dann wollte es braucht ja
kraus ja vor glauben am nächsten morgen
fit wirkte den besonderen ausflug auf
die bank sie weiß was er will hat mich
selbst immer die townships kurz zu
machen ich kann und ich glaube das ist
ein wort das gerät mega organisiertes
und durchstrukturiert chronik sondern
erzählt wie schön noch einmal das bild
nicht um geld es vor diesen elend ist
richtig aber auf das was kommt der mond
der sonne taucht die eines tricks
kapitel vor der südafrikanischen
geschichte während der apartheid
geschrieben sind wohngebiete der stadt
strikt noch und von pixie lott ecke für
wissen und c für sport sie uns kollektiv
immer wenig zeit hat
langer townships älteste orgel viertens
kapstadt die wiese noch den hausherrn
vor knapp 100 jahren baut damit sie die
schwarze us energie birte höhne für
briefe und daher geschickt wurde tim
lange township rund 50.000 vom volk vor
der pause
[Musik]
schoofs näher
seiter andile dass wir nochmal
schlachthof
vor begeisterung auf
jeder kunde bewohner von lohra township
für gc new york jeden tag touristen
diskutieren und zeige deine wie sie
damit mit einer führung verdient die
heimische ganz sie sind wichtig das
township und so steht man als fremder
brechts mixed im lager vor dem anpfiff
[Musik]
gegen den transport siegburg der 4
darum sind illegale pops entstanden die
sind bis heute treffpunkt von tradition
[Musik]
um komplexe bier bringt mit sammelns ein
großer dichte hecke
[Gelächter]
ganz großartig finde ein verhältnis mit
bier zu
[Musik]
obere bis anderes wetter dafür
gegenmittel liter teilen sind freut oder
neue township getan wenn es um musik
geht führt in langa dir kein weg an
einem haus vorbei henrici musi ich muss
[Musik]
so energietage sieht euer eigen da keine
schließt die schon zum studium die roste
townships
[Musik]
er ist unschuldig bekennen
ich bin stolz auf die spanischen
fluglotsen mit dem musikmachen
er ist jetzt klar
ich sage aber das ist sowohl und und und
liebevoll sind dh ich glaube sie sind
dies darf ich bin musiker verhindert bei
schönstem auf das schärfste
[Musik]
und dann hat sich sogar schon überwinden
aber sie tritt mit stunden im leben sind
[Musik]
jetzt konnte manu den punkt durch sind
gepackt ist
[Musik]
nein
ich habe und die vorgaben sind
freundlich des albums will das ist jetzt
wohl jeder bringt und ich noch gehen ihr
besonderes 1000 taliban sich doch zwei
und jetzt ist dort wird die folge jeder
gibt alles schneidige babys
[Musik]
warum
mit demi moore jüngst ihr zwei
kapstadt/südafrika woche musik kilometer
und ganz viel überraschungen
die zwei einig dass sie mehr als einmal
die tatsache mit back große tier und
musiker hoffen auf höhere welle und tief
erhöhen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der geist johannesburg die erste etappe
führt sie über die berge vorstellen boss
auf hermanns
[Musik]
schon auch es braucht kilometer holte
tony mono hat will die dir in willich
zins entwickeln es ist sie sind spielt
wird ja ja ja richtig afrika und jetzt
vorschlägt auto konto der autobahn
[Musik]
nicht leisten
sie haben recht so er wird durch oder
weiblich 1
[Musik]
mit nur zwei wichtigsten boss
es sind noch fünf kilometer bbc
der bus liegt mit die berge und das
herzstück vor der wii produktion
südafrika
stellenbosch weingut das wie quads
gehört zu den besten im land vor der
townships kapstadt die aktive privat vom
edlen tropfen sich ein kulturschock für
die 2 es ist eine wohnung mit dem rad
und jagten schnitt und musik des duos
[Musik]
da kann es draußen in der sonne sind
nicht die einzige spitze der johnny hat
für den nur wenige station organisiert
[Musik]
wir sind vor der hütte kleines bier
getrunken und da ist mir peinlich dass
ich so eine sache
wichtig ist etwas glück kann ist aber
nicht wirklich nennen wie dem thema ich
dem mann aus st
die situation
diese können
[Musik]
der zweite dort auf rekord langsam fand
der 900 juni ziehen und mit jeder wollen
wie das sag ich dir jetzt sieht 15
das ist sehr spannend da schmeckt ganz
glücklich der südhang am nächsten morgen
dass ich für das wie die letzte nach dem
vorbild der früheren schön einfach aber
megaschön und liegt so warmherzig jedem
satz
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jetzt freilich wird ab jetzt weiß ich
nicht was gut und ich kann mich nun muss
und er zitiert
ich war bewegt wird durch stimmen
[Applaus]
vorstellen was ganz wichtig ist steht
die hermanis
[Musik]
h
viele hoch
genauso stück zu
doch funkspruch tod gestorben
dies kommt man auch wenn da alle machen
ohne
[Musik]
die hochzeitsglocken bekommen
remmel
[Musik]
sind
sie schoss gab es nicht
hey
[Musik]
ja ich denke es ist einfach
kontrollieren aber mit denen
windgeschützt grunde das mehr ist als
plastikbäume manchmal nicht ganz mehrere
dass wir im winter platziert plötzlich
aber noch haben wir platz haben
[Musik]
nein
doch
[Musik]
in trebur staatsmann und johnny genießen
den sonnenuntergang am meer ein
stacheldraht und nicht vor
new york
eigentlich
mit ashley romantik bayern verpasste
seinen untergang retten
[Musik]
der ausschuss auf die trauern nicht
liebt
[Musik]
mit mir aber jetzt will ich brauche
ruhige nacht lässt erobert
es ist ein team und sind natürlich schön
mit dem motto unterwegs sie wieder mal
ein mensch ist wo begeistern kann zeigen
und das macht freude wenn man kommt rum
und macht sich das große hobby also vom
schuss und ich sehe die größte
so ist alles klar
das hätte jetzt nie dank wie nacht also
haben einmal den kopfstützen nach ist
und das ist echt anders
trainer hans zach und t shirt und mit
bully ich habe nach einer viertelstunde
dieser stelle südafrika und schottland
hand mehr gemeinsam und mit dank
[Musik]
spanisch ist wie der andere co
oder bringen
[Musik]
detern vom velo fordert und wie wichtig
rooney zum und schließt wir aber
kombination dudic und den wird in der
woche geht's weiter mit der leistung
südafrika
[Musik]
divertimento in südafrika mit
globetrotter m spezialist für
maßgeschneiderte reise wald wie
globetrotter der punkt ch